this episode brought to you by hello
fresh delicious pre-measured ingredients
and simple chef made recipes delivered
to your doorstep every week
[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to most of
us know the classic story of Stuart
Little
EB White's timeless tale of a little
mouse who lives with a human family goes
on the silliest of adventures and
overcomes his fears resulting in the
happiest of endings
well you don't remember dick because
that's not what this book is like at all
despite millions reading it many block
out the nonsensical insanity that Stuart
little actually was for starters he's
not a mouse he's a human that looks like
a mouse and he's not adopted his mother
just pushed him out that way at the age
of seven he acts and talks like he's 16
he befriends a bird who runs away and he
uses a gas-powered toy car with a magic
invisible lever to find her he takes a
job as a substitute teacher along the
way dates a girl who happens to be the
exact same height but blows it because
his toy canoe is destroyed and she
freaks out by his temper tantrum keep in
mind this is the climax
thus he drives north still searching for
the bird never finding her and that's
where it stops
it literally ends right there back then
critics were like what the hell are you
high but kids seem to love it and I
guess it made sense
it's a weird bizarre story told in a
very grounded and low-key way but how
strange that so many people remember it
being such a normal run-of-the-mill kids
book when it was anything but well hell
out of that may have to do with the
movie who had the difficult task of
taking this wildly odd journal of
madness and turning it into a profitable
family film how do Hollywood writers
make such a giant hit out of such
strangeness the answer is they don't
this is in fact the very first film to
be written entirely by the 90s they just
gave the 90s the book of Zack Morris
cellphone ate it up and out a pair
of khakis in a v-neck sweater upgrade
from the director of the haunted mansion
and lime King with the script by M night
Shyamalan no really who made this
Stewart little as an attempt to give
audiences an adaptation of the book they
thought they read you can pretty much
call this film the Mandela effect as it
only loosely follows the strangeness of
the book and his dead gives us light
run-of-the-mill family fluff a tweet for
some reason remember the book being is
it an improvement on the literary
drunken ramble or is it the 90s ever
crime being bitch a lot of money with no
substance now let's see if things were
better safe than crazy this is Stewart
little so how can we hammer in were in
the 90s hi Jerry Maguire kid I'd like to
take some shots on how overly cutesy his
acting is but seeing how he can probably
kick my ass now I'm just gonna stick
with all some twin jokes hi sweetie
ah the 90s when even boarding a bus had
to have whimsical music
let's stop ooh and see whimsy and human
I can't emphasize that enough this is
George little his parents played by
Geena Davis and Hugh Laurie are off to
the orphanage to adopt a brother for him
Oh none of these kids are mice this
place blows
they of course come across Stuart voiced
by Michael J Fox who tries to give them
advice on which kid would be the best
for them it happens the same way every
time first you won't know what to do
you'll be a little bit scared and you'll
meet one of them talk to me somehow you
just know okay let's be honest it the
dialogue for this character was written
for a kid instead of a mouse he would
totally look like a serial killer it
happens the same way every time
first you won't know what to do you'll
be a little scared then you'll meet one
event talk to them and somehow you'll
just know
anti-god
[Music]
the credits give us a pretty nice shot
of the city thank God we focus on the
clouds through most of them
New York is such a boring place to shoot
and bring Stuart to his new home as
featured in several Disney properties
they say every little in the world can
find this house even if they've never
been here before I'm just gonna guess
and say that's a shot mol online you
just like a tour I don't have any money
I'm just gonna guess and say that wasn't
a shell mole online cuz it actually got
a laugh out of me an attentional one but
George is unimpressed with his new
brother or perhaps at the fact that the
littles seem to have a strength fetish
come on Tim Burton and the Cat in the
Hat have more variety than you have
anything you wanna ask Stuart go ahead
I'm an open book
something the writers of this clearly
didn't do at first sure Ali med is kind
of fighting Stuart among the regular
sized house and appliances though it
doesn't look like he's actually there he
does come across as very expressive and
y'all just said cute he's very cute but
the family film formula starts
to take hold when their cat named
Snowbell enters the picture Stuart is
one of the family now we do not eat
family members did they really not think
this would be an issue I mean in the
book he's just born that way and they
happen to already have a cat here it's
like buying an ant farm to get along
with your pet and eater
it's bad odds maybe I can help what do
you like can I can I scratch yours okay
place your bets which gay 90's actor
voices him for brunettes Sean Hayes or
miscellaneous queer I guy 10 so I'm I'm
Way past 10 Lane of course lighting
director I still connected the dots this
is my family can't we share read my
furry pink lips my poorly
computer-generated borrow from babe lips
no
Oh full house music here's some USC pics
offsetting the cue pandering that's sure
to lie ahead they match so little they
kind of match perfectly Stewart gets
thrown in the washing machine though and
tries getting help from Snowbell oh I've
got to stare at traffic yawn licked
myself and believe me that could take
hours if you do it right that wasn't
alive from the script that's just when
Nathan Lane said he was gonna do after
the shoot mrs. little gets him out in
time and dr. Dabney Coleman looks him
over delivering a line so bad that only
Dabney Coleman could possibly make it
funny he's gonna be fine very clean how
did he make that line magic I don't know
mr. little talks to George about giving
his mousy brother a fair chance but it
quickly for no reason turns into a talk
about boats you want to race your boat
George it's like trying an American
accent you just do it have fun and don't
listen to the critics I like that they
shop for Stuart's party clothes in the
doll section of a toy store but what
kind of party has everybody arrived at
the exact same time oh you can't say
that anymore great job right it's not PC
suit I don't know nothing's PC anymore
they introduced Stuart to the family and
they give him gift they're way too big
for him because the parents never told
anyone he was a mouse the thought occurs
to me that these parents are really
awful I got Billy a skateboard oh I
forgot to tell you Billy's in a
wheelchair oh well I got sippy a hair
part oh I forgot to tell you Cindy has
no head oh I got Johnny some sneakers
Johnny's a bear let's find this
orphanage but George is still angry that
his new brother as a mouse at least I
think that's the emotion he's going for
are you all not bicycles and bowling
balls
how's he incasa baseball how is he gonna
do any of those things it's not my
brother he's a mouse
remember when the Olsen twins said
you're in big trouble mister that was
dumb I just wanted to ask you something
why did you want to ask us about my real
family look like well sure they were
Jewish immigrants and they said they
lost you at sea but they just didn't
like you very much so mr. and mrs.
little go to find out about Stewart's
original parents it's out of the
question and it's against the rules
besides it's very hard to track Mouse
families they're not very good with
paperwork oh I mean we all think it but
we never say what the meanwhile
tries to get along with Snowbell again
but another cat enters the house and we
partake in clearly cats not acting but
we're just gonna put lips on them like
they are yeah you look pale maybe you
should see a vet AFET what a swell idea
do you know anybody I'm not so happy
with mine now that's just lazy am i
right Chaplin I'm not even in the same
location it's you right
here's a riddle which one of these is
the lifeless CG puppet idea when the
Olsens released that greatest hits CD I
bet they're fizz artists deal hard as
this guy's George gives steward the
iconic toy car remember so well from the
book so naturally he takes it for a
higher boat like the movie Stuart helps
George finish the boat for the big race
but Snowbell is finally fed up and looks
for outside help a mouse with a pet cat
that's sick I can't can't have eroded
from master word of this gets out it'll
be bad for cats all over it'll be the
worst thing to happen to cats since Rome
cats don't worry think about I'm all
over it you're right what a high I mean
come on Belle would have worked on two
levels but so the day of the race
arrives and their boat named wasp yes
I'm so surprised they call it that too
it's ready to float
okay how did they make a toy boat look
evil ships from Pirates of the Caribbean
don't look that evil he George what did
you do get that out of a cereal box oh
don't tell me you're the owner of that
boat
someone's got to finish last I didn't
know I wanted a series about dr. evil as
an eight-year-old but thank you please
am I totally down gotta be a shallow
online can't you just see you following
up with you like hot dogs right
Stewart drops the remote though much too
Anton and his boat posses delight come
on boys we have a lego Tea Party at a
toy Yacht Club gee however will they
resolve this I'm blown away with
indifference oh I mean uh you got a dude
was weird George
[Music]
surprisingly straightforward answer I
was wondering why we built this with a
functioning steering wheel a toast to
improbable technics only does about
demolish another kids boat but he has a
boy bodyguard shove the driver away how
nineties bullies this is a special cloud
and lazy heaven waiting for you is there
would be if they weren't so lazy this is
serious toy boat race I've ever seen in
my life so your mouse brother might die
we still to follow the rules of the race
of which I think every single one has
been broken
that Mouse anyway that's no mouse that's
my brother he has an a pac-man take that
main antagonist we introduced halfway
through the movie and we'll never speak
up again seriously though I'm gonna miss
you
[Applause]
[Music]
you nail do you like school question is
that of course I like food I needed to
live do do do you like light absolutely
love it
though I'm not exactly the best cook
[Music]
meals can be very difficult but all of
that will change with hellofresh
hellofresh is a mule-kick delivery
service that shops plans and deliver
step-by-step recipes and pre-measured
ingredients so you can just cook it add
dry as home-cooked meals made simple and
then fresh makes conquering the kitchen
of reality with deliciously simple
recipes as someone who's not a very good
cook I'm not a very good cook but
following these instructions makes it so
easy silence now cooking is enjoyable
and easy with Hello fresh fresh
pre-measured ingredients and
easy-to-follow six-step pictured recipe
cards are delivered to your door each
week in a special insulated box all
meals come together in 30 minutes max
call for less than two pots and pans and
require minimal or cleanup make
deliciousness part of your every week
with three plans to choose from
classic veggie and family with the
option to switch between four when your
tastes change you can also enjoy fun
menu features with hello freshers dinner
to lunch TM 20 minute meals gourmet and
one-pot wonders among more another great
thing about is you don't have to follow
the recipe exactly you can add your own
spices and flavors and make it your own
of course I forgot I'm not very good at
that so I just follow the recipe and it
turned out a lot better there's nothing
better going from fast food to real food
made fast quiet for we have a special
offer now for $80 off your first month
of hellofresh
go to hello fresh duck arms last
nostalgia a tea and enter nostalgia a
tea again that's hello fresh stockholm /
tea for your $80 offer
first month of hellofresh it's like
receiving eight meals for free so go to
hello fresh calm slash nostalgia eighty
and enter nostalgia ET for your special
offer today
[Music]
[Applause]
Stewart and George of course win the big
race both they get some unexpected
visitors welllook of us do it are you
friends of his we're his parents yeah we
were looking for his brother Algernon
that didn't pan out so we'll take
whoever you got so Stewart's parents
played by Bruno Kirby and Jennifer Tilly
say they wants to her back because they
now have the financial capacity to take
care of him
Stuart's human parents again cementing
how awful they are at this tell Stuart
he needs to go with him George give
Stuart the toy car and they drive away
to his new home and an abandoned
miniature golf course sleep tight don't
let the bedbugs bite
yeah I'm serious about those bedbugs
keep an eye open the spider named
Charlotte smells nice but she will eat
you the family tries adjusting to life
without Stuart but the woman from the
orphanage says that Stuart's parents are
dead
there was an unsteady pyramid of cans
and it collapsed they had to identify
them by their dental records cream of
mushroom soup two-for-one sale am I
supposed to movie seriously big one
Stuart's parents came and took him away
three days ago Stuart's parents died in
a tragic cream mushroom soup incident
years ago I just told you oh my god oh
my god even in Stuart little it's still
worth frigging little this still has to
be a Shyamalan twist I don't get it you
wouldn't even a thing yet why stop there
how about Stuart is actually dead the
littles are actually superheroes and the
trees what the hell's that happening
again I don't know just tell fairy tale
you weirdo Oh God fairy tale
Doyle the police arrived as it's
revealed its no bail and the other cats
who set this up you scratch him out
what's smokey the police are involved I
don't want to get kicked out of my house
so would he go to jail if mice can be
adopted can felines do time you don't
refit in if you start working on
prisoners of law it's settled Stuart
little get scratched tonight okay all
right I'll give you credit Stuart little
you made that adorable cat terrifying if
I was a thug in Batman I'd actually be
more afraid of this than Michael Keaton
to kill you I want you to tell all your
friends about me are you I'm Batman what
are our chances of seeing Stuart again
you want it straight no absolutely not
Stuart's probably home right now waiting
for you again i legit funny scene I wish
I could stop them and put them on my
mantle it gets a little weirdly dark
though it's my guess these two sickos on
some kind of cross country Mouse killing
spree so where is that book on the
grisly photos look at Desmond Oh have
fun knowing what happens in this
universe kids oh oh wait run movies
still what what are we doing Stuart's
parents admit they're not his parents
and they were threatened to lie to him
about being so which makes Stuart happy
knowing he's still a little I'm gonna
let us doubt them a little I'm Stuart
Little
[Music]
not a nineties film unless this was
reference somehow oh wait a minute
let's stop blewett's Stewart drives back
home via an unusually long shot of
Central Park clouds and blackness 'no
cinematography is got a ton of cats
corner him he rides his car into the
sewer though and gets away he makes it
home and discovers Snowbell is the only
one there ever since you left is just
movies parties rollerskating they were
just so happy to get rid of you okay
seriously at this point wouldn't it make
sense just to eat him the family already
thinks he's gone Snowbell could just
gobble him up and nobody would know
dramatically why go through another lie
just to drag things out or did I just
answer my own question I tried to warn
you Stewart I told you it wasn't gonna
work out don't wait sorry so we need
this is very relatable drama we've all
been adopted just to find our real
parents just to find their fake parents
just to find our adoptive parents again
just to find they hate us just to find
they don't hate us stop reading my
journal of course his family is actually
out putting up flyers and they just miss
each other even snow Belle's lies about
the family hating him are so harsh it
kind of makes it hard to like him again
it's just so over the top relentlessly
mean they did that right after you left
and George she gave it to him and he
tore it up I'd give you the pieces but
mr. little set them on fire well and I
just found out your real parents they're
dead and there is no God
but there is a hell and they're going to
it and so are you you're gonna love me
by the end the other cats ask Snowbell
to track him down kid no it's not like
we didn't just have a big chasing with
cats and they locate him down in Central
Park didn't your mother's warned you not
to go into Central Park at night my
mother was the reason you didn't go with
the Central Park at night you know damn
it will be stopped going in a good line
every once in a while I want to hate all
of you there's no bail fine Stewart
though it decides to protect him from
the rest of the cats I'm doing this for
the littles all right I lied okay I'm
the one that hates you
don't care he literally just said he
hates you
this mean he's supposed to be redeemed
now I can just no what's he doing to
your leg what the hell is going on just
give it a can of swear word
what the hell is going on well then
hilariously doesn't fit oh wait I forgot
there's literally no other reason for
this movie to be PG and you know we got
to let the cool kids know that Stuart
little has an edge who can't says he'll
parental guidance is needed
parental guidance was neither went
riding this damn movie Stuart for what
the 12th time gives a speech about what
being a family is all about sure you'll
probably scratch him up pretty bad
you'll tear him to shreds you may even
kill him but Snowbell will not run away
right snow that's what should have been
there but instead what just get snow
Bell looking afraid so what would that
have been too much would have warranted
a pg-13 picket separated for a bit but
Snowbell catches them on a loose branch
and start slowing them into the water
I'm sure you know if only they had cam
reflexes to jump off pity they're dogs
but there's one cat left
[Music]
maybe it's because of my cat owner now
but I feel a JIT bad for these animals
how many times did they have to smack
him in the face or drop him in the water
because the director of the haunted
mansion said the film wouldn't be
complete without it this guy killed
Simba's dad kitties you don't want to
work with him
Snowbell bring Stuart home and the
littles are united this is how people
look at the end of a fairy tale yeah at
the end of Annie be white book but a
fairy tale
sure and there was to read little it's
bland dated and forgettable but I
suppose it is inoffensive I mean yes the
book is strange and unique and I would
have liked it did the movie attempted to
tell something strange and unique but at
the same time I think most people going
in no they're not gonna give what the
original book was with this and instead
kiss I'm tired but not really harmful
cliches some of them are even enjoyably
bad like the out of nowhere bully and
the weird swearing cat I do give credit
to an occasional funny line and some
expressive animation from Stuart but it
truly is an in one Mouse ear out the
other kind of boredom trading in the
strange bizarreness of the book for the
safe coziness of the 90s I can't say
there's much to recommend in it but I
can't say there's much you should avoid
at all cost either not offensive but not
imagined and either
hopefully you can figure out if this is
the right nineties cheese for your inner
mouse that no nostalgia critic and by
god I had to balance out all this cutesy
bland is with something tougher and
awesome oh look a segue into next week's
review we're doing two naughty
[Music]
hi the Walker here mission 22 is this
week's charity shout out mission 22 is a
nonprofit who combats the ever rising
veteran suicide rate every day more than
20 veterans are lost to suicide mission
22 wants to bring that number to zero it
does this with three main programs
veteran treatment programs memorials and
national awareness mission 22 provides
treatment programs to veterans for
post-traumatic stress traumatic brain
injury and other issues they might be
facing it organizes events and builds
memorials to create social impact and
awareness for these issues through these
programs and enables a push for the
betterment of our nation's heroes and
stands United in the war against veteran
suicide if you want to show your thanks
and your care for all that these people
have sacrificed click on the link and
show these people who have given up so
much that there are so many things worth
living for
you
[Music]